The robots have the cartoons and movies
from the 19 seventies are going to be
the reality of the 20 slash 20 and there
are two real drivers behind this.
First is mapping belief space.
Historically it's been really difficult
to be able to instruct robots to do
things like grasping,
grasping might seem like a pretty
straightforward thing to do,
but it's actually very complex
mathematically and algorithmically to be
able to instruct robots how to do that.
And so what this mathematical
breakthrough in mapping belief space has
done is it as taken what are
historically very complex tasks for
robots and made them easier to do.
The second thing is cloud robotics.
So if c three Po right now,
if he walked over here and interrupted
this big think interview,
he would say,
oh my,
excuse me,
you know,
and,
and get out of the frame.
And as he did this,
there would be a lot of hardware and
software worrying in that gold claiming
body of his.
In reality the c three Po of the 20
slash 20 will be a cloud connected
device.
And so what he would do if he stumbled
into this interview is he is he would
ping the cloud and he would get
instructions from the hive mind that is
their algorithmically and he would then
know to excuse himself to do so in
English and two though,
then go clunk away.
So what does this mean?
What this means is that the robots of
our youths and of our imaginations don't
have to have millions of dollars of
incredibly sophisticated hardware and
software in them.
They can be relatively lightweight dumb
devices so long as they're connected to
the power of the cloud.
So what's the significance?
Okay.
So they're cheaper.
So what the big significance here really
goes to labor.
So let's think about the difference
between humans and robots and their
costs.
Humans don't have a lot of cap ex,
but they have a lot of opex.
So the upfront costs costs,
you know,
maybe your employer buys you some
business cards,
maybe gets you a computer for work or
something like that.
Not a lot of cap ex,
not a lot of upfront costs,
but a lot of opex every two weeks.
You want to get paid,
right?
Lot of salary,
lot of op ex robots come with
diametrically opposed cost structure.
It's a lot of cap ex.
You've got to buy the robot,
but then relatively little objects,
you can work them 24 hours a day.
They aren't going to join a union or get
sick and they don't expect to salary and
so what's happening right now is we're
seeing new equilibrium points in terms
of the tradeoff between the relative
cost of a cap backs,
intense opex,
slight robot and a cap ex light opics in
high labor of humans.
I saw this in all places in East Asia,
in the football field,
size factories of Fox con,
the Taiwanese company that makes all of
our smartphones and Terry Gou,
the CEO of Foxconn who employs 973,000
people,
has decided he's not hiring anymore
humans.
He's just buying robots.
And so I think that this is.
This is fascinating stuff.
As the robots have,
the cartoons and movies become the
reality of the 20 twenties.
They aren't going to look like the
metallic out the metallic robots have of
the cartoons and movies that are
actually going to look more human
because of advances in material sciences
from electroactive polymers to to silk
skin to air muscles and other such
things,
so the robots are the future may
actually look more like terminator than
like Star Wars.
What's also interesting that's happening
right now is,
particularly in Japan and South Korea,
there are robots being developed.
The purpose of which is actually to do
what we normally think of as the most
intimate human tasks to do things like
take care of our aging grandparents and
part of this is flowing from an economic
imperative and Japan,
for example,
Japan has the world's oldest population
and it's only growing older and so
companies like Toyota and Honda.
Yup.
The ones that make the cars are now
making elder care robots because there
aren't enough young Japanese to take
care of the grandparents and so things
that we think of as very intimate and
very human in the future will be
increasingly robotic.
It's not a surprise that this is coming
out of Asia.
Interestingly,
in societies like Japan,
where Shinto is the Nash is the national
religion.
In Shinto,
for example,
they have a belief in animism that
objects can have souls,
and so that's a big difference than
Judeo Christian religions,
which think of objects as being a
soulless and if you contrast the culture
and mythology of a lot of Asian
societies,
it's much more embracing of automation
and robotics as opposed to western
societies were from icarus with his wax
wings to Frankenstein and beyond.
Most of our culture,
most of our mythology is rooted in the
risks of giving life to those things
that perhaps we ought not to.
So I don't think it's a big surprise
that a lot of these innovations are
coming from East Asia.